joining us from MLB network as well as
Fox Sports the baseball hall-of-famer
himself John Smoltz how you doing John
I'm doing good
October 7th I probably won't be doing
good at all
why is that Michigan Michigan State oh
gosh now John Cohen come on that's
that's uh normally I look forward to it
now it's queasy stomach I mean you never
know I mean you know no no no we know we
know it's going to be a nice little
spurt you guys are going to have what do
you mean by spurt what do you mean by
spurt well seven you know up until last
year yeah seven-year run for the
Spartans I think that's going to be gone
for a while well I think it was a
six-year run that was aided into a
seventh due to a special team snafued
that wouldn't happen 999 times out of
the other thousand stairs correct you
know but right but the final score is
what it is that's it we could put a pin
in that and revisit that in October
absolutely what do you think if the
Dodgers don't make the World Series is
this season a complete failure well you
know so much that people don't
understand I mean we went 14 straight
years and made the World Series what
five times um had the best record a lot
of those years and didn't qualify for
the World Series because there's so many
contributing factors I I understand the
game and how it operates in the
postseason with TB and travel but think
about it 162 games in 180 days the best
team is going to have the best record
because of the depth of that short 18
day off days right I mean these you got
you got to face 1 to 1 you gotta have a
five-man rotation and you can't you
can't limp in like you can't limp in
with two and a half starters although
last year the Dodgers proved that wrong
but I have to have in 632 pitching
changes or whatever it was my point is
when you get to the postseason you've
got so many off days and teams that can
get in that don't have the best record
but maybe have two hot starters can give
you fits can make it very difficult so
to answer the question fairly they have
the most pressure on them now that the
Cubs won last year they have not been to
the World Series in 30 years
so the year they're having yeah the
pressure for them to get to a little
series is greater than anybody else it
just because the record is what it is I
don't think it's easy to say it's a
failure they are the most balanced and
they have the most depth but a matchup
problem is right there in the making if
they get into a scenario what I just
mentioned you get too hot pitchers and
they find themselves on the outside
looking in just because of the format in
the postseason so which is the team they
want to see least then I would think the
Nationals a healthy Nationals team this
was a really really an interesting
series last year no Strasburg epic fifth
game in depending on how to look at it
if you like seven pitchers in one inning
which happened I think in the seventh
inning it took an hour-and change but I
think the the Nationals possess about
offense that is so good an offense that
could get better with Turner and Werth
and all the left-handed pitching that
the Dodgers have although be it great
Darvish makes a difference of course
that helps mix up the lefties that are
in that rotation but your matchups in
the National League are going to be
great no matter who it is because those
teams are far and away better than the
rest of the league whereas the American
League has a more bunched in kind of
wild-card scenario and maybe those teams
aren't as as deep as the the front three
so the matchups are going to be
intriguing they're going to be great
the Dodgers are going to get the
wild-card team and and that is going to
be what it is and then we move on from
there well I mean the wild-card team
could be Arizona right and see Zack
Greinke sitting right there though I
mean that's a pitcher that you could see
twice and you know the Rockies are
always an intriguing team and if I'm at
on that note mmm Zack Greinke more
unlikely he's on pitch that wildcard
games so I want to get some one game in
the series interesting best of five
that's drink I think that's what I I
used to always get kind of ridiculed for
my philosophy if you're a wild-card team
and you really are thinking about when
in the World Series why would you pitch
your best pitcher in the in the
wild-card game and I used to get crushed
for this because the reality is do you
want to
in one game or do you want to win the
best chance of one at eleven and my
argument is it's a condensed horse form
anyways it's Johnny bullpen and your
starter gives you five innings turn over
to your pen I know you got a win to get
in I get that but the year that the
Cardinals won the whole thing
they saved two Carpenter and didn't
pitch him the last game of the year and
banked on us beating Houston we did they
set up carpenter for the rest of the
playoffs they won the one the World
Series because they had the best pitcher
available more often well then let's get
deeper in the weeds on this because the
the best part about Darvish being
acquired by the Dodgers John is in my
opinion the fact that they could throw
Kershaw on regular rest during long
series as opposed to his previous
appearances I just saw earlier this
month that he's thrown more starts in
the postseason on short rest and then
regular rest which is amazing and
Bumgarner's never thrown on short rest
in a start
obviously great so what is your
philosophy on putting your best pitcher
dyou you throw your best pitcher in Game
one or Game three so you would have Game
one and five on regular rest or as
opposed to three and seven on regular oh
yeah that that's always the the game
five and that's why was talking about
why the matchups you're going to have
the teams that are don't have as great a
chance to move on they're going to be
pressed to faced to have their pitchers
pitch on short rest well if you've got
good depth and you trust your starters
to win 11 games Kershaw on regular rest
is way better than the kind of heroic
kind of three see that's what the
Indians ran into last year when everyone
talked about how great their bullpen was
and it was but you can't use your
bullpen like that year in and year out
and Kluber had to pitch on three games
rest every single day and did a great
job until the final time he had to do it
he just didn't have his stuff so you you
have to have four if you have about four
really good pitchers you set yourself up
for the best scenario to win eleven
games if you're just looking to knock
somebody off and keep advancing you need
two hot pitchers and two hot pitchers
can beat you in a best-of-five series
and then of course back in the day used
to be you know game one starter would go
one four and seven
and the game has changed where we don't
see that with the exceptions of like a
clayton kershaw did last year john
smoltz few more minutes here with him on
the Rich Eisen show I've seen it seems
like I've been asking this every time
you've been on the show John during the
season uh about the Cubs I think they're
officially playing with fire here now
we're in the middle of August and
they've got two teams two teams that
they have to deal with and the Pirates
are still on the periphery here do you
think the Cubs are making the playoffs
when it's all said and done ultimately I
still do
III think the fact that this thing got
tightened up the thing that concerns me
is the moves they've made have not
worked out of the pen that has been
their Peniston their issue you know we
were worried about their starters as a
whole for a while that's been corrected
Hendricks is back arrieta's back so they
gotta figure out what's happening to
some of these guys to get to Davis I
mean call it woods juniors been lights
out until recently and the same things
Wilson has come over and not been as so
to me that's their issue they're
allowing teams to function in a bullpen
that Joe Maddon was pretty confident in
and you know if you even think about it
going into last year he lost confidence
and some guys down the stretch and had
to win that series with basically
starters coming out of the pen and then
Chapman of course pitching all those
innings so it's it's it is the race the
only race in the National League and
some teams look like they've got some
flaws but are hanging in there and could
win that division but ultimately I still
believe that when you look around in
that clubhouse they got to feel like a
despite the word the defending champions
we're still better we just got to play a
little better well I mean I know you're
not on Twitter last night John Lackey
was trending and I didn't see why and I
thought oh my god did he get hurt that
would be horrible for the Cubs and then
I realized he was trending because he
stole a base at age 38 and I noticed
John you have three career stolen bases
yeah yeah what we observe what I broke
into the league is the official pinch
runner for Russ Nixon believe it or not
and I used to pinch run for our catchers
I had two emergency
pinch-run earlier than he told me to in
San Diego I did not have my spikes on
the video is priceless I couldn't find
my my helmet I was panicking because I
had turf shoes on and Milk Duds in my
back pocket not a good not a good
scenario for pinch running when Benito
Santiago is behind the plate okay a
small lead I was worried about being
picked off I was worried about traction
I got thrown out at second sliding in on
my Milk Duds which ruined my day and I
got yelled at by my manager for not
having my spikes on so although that was
fun to actually pinch run and it wasn't
later in my career is fun I was on third
base in Game six of the World Series
with Otis Nixon at the plate and Timlin
in the mound and the third base coast of
time Williams said to me he's going to
bunt you've got to beat the throw to
home because he doesn't look like he's
gonna be able to swing off at m1 and I'm
telling you that whole thought of
getting thrown out or running over the
catcher in Game six so they can have it
yes I had a couple stolen bases got one
in the you know the playoffs and you
know sneaky speed when I was younger but
then straight Leadfoot
to caught stealing stooge on to caught
yeah one of almost cheap I slid I was
safe I got past the bag and they tagged
me I had a little I argued that one I
didn't win but yeah so but you it's very
rare to hear the excuse I had Milk Duds
in my pocket that's a good one but I was
that was an embarrassing moment in San
Diego Yankees Red John Key's Red Sox
this weekend and then we see the
American League wild card completely
wide open
this is truly a lot of fun what who do
you think is in fact standing and that
was a lot of fun and my dream scenario I
don't think that's what baseball wants I
want like a four-way playoff I want to
see what happens with a four-way playoff
to get down to a two team to get down to
one but and this is the closest year
we've ever had to that possibly
happening I said this a month and a half
ago I just had this feeling about the
Rangers they were six or seven back
it didn't look good they traded away
Darvish they trade away some pieces look
Lucroy I I think man wait if they got a
really good chance and yes there's five
teams ahead of them but they're two
games back everyone's got a chance so
whoever gets hot at the right time is
going to be huge but I think the big
thing when you're sitting in this
position you know and you're two games
back in five in front of you you start
feeling in the club ah so I think we're
better than this team I think we're
better than that team you got to have
some confidence in your club where's
your edge and some of these teams have
lost their edge because of BIA trades
and the fact that they haven't performed
well and whether they're bullpen or
one-run games so it's wide open I kind
of like it and I think it's going to be
for fun baseball down the stretch even
if these teams aren't necessarily I
don't like to use the word flawed but
maybe not running on on all their
engines I think there's a reality that
sits there and goes we get in we could
get dangerous who knows we've seen it
with the Giants we've seen it with one
hot pitcher so that scenario plays out
in the American League that's where all
the eyes are great chatting with you
John great chatting with you really
enjoyed it and we'll we'll talk down the
line before the playoffs hopefully you
got a few guys John Smoltz MLB Network
Fox voice so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our apps
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slo-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about